hôtel recherche perd le rare pour une
saison inoubliable
voici l'annoncé publiée en avril par des
professionnels acculé en quête de main
d'oeuvre
vous voulez une autre façon de recruter
une autre façon nous nous percevoir avec
les gens se disent ben c'est une
entreprise dynamique a établi son
dynamique on voudrait vraiment allé les
voir et travaille avec le succès a été
fulgurant 90000 vue et parmi les
candidats alexis 24 ans aujourd'hui à
l'essai séduit par ce recrutement peu
académique pour candidater par exemple
un poste normalement n'ayant pas
d'expérience surtout normalement on
envoie son cv la lettre de motivation et
parfois on reçoit même pas de réponse
ici le système d a fonctionné mais
certains comme ludovic nicolau veulent
aller plus loin
ce cher bourgeois démarche les
restaurateurs avec une toute nouvelle
application un job
vous avez juste à cliquer sur le bouton
et que vous avez la présentation du
candidat
bonjour je suis françoise tu as les
candidats postent des vidéos sur leur
mobile les recruteurs n'ont plus qu'à
faire leur choix pendant longtemps
faisait une lettre manuscrite à la main
et face à ces dangers
voilà ce qu'avait l'employeur pour pour
sélectionner son candidat
comment il écrivait le nombre de fautes
si c'était bien personnaliser tout ça
c'est fini
et bah apparemment c'est fini maintenant
on a une petite vidéo pourquoi pas cv
expérience tout y y et en quelques clics
l'application permet aux professionnels
de savoir si le candidat correspond et
vous pouvez tout faire des respirations
mobile
lui envoyer un message et vous pouvez
convenir yatch à la rendez vous les
solutions de recrutement aujourd'hui
elle reste coûteuse et elles prennent du
temps et donc avec mon job ce que l'on
essaie de faire c'est vraiment de ma
porte est une solution efficace à ces
contraintes gratuite pour les candidats
à l embauche
bon job compte déjà 850 abonnés dans
toute la france